and speaking of things to monitor in
Indonesia that country has raised its
alert status for the erupting volcano
that caused a deadly tsunami over the
weekend the 16-foot ocean wave killed at
least 430 people on the islands of Java
and Sumatra people along the coastline
are being told to stay in 'land for
fears of another tsunami and now
air travelers too are on alert Elizabeth
Palmer is in London monitoring the
situation for us
Elizabeth good morning good morning
that's right aircrafts are being
rerouted around the volcano today and so
are boats which aren't being allowed
within three miles of the island that
the volcano sits on anak Krakatau --is
major eruption and the resulting tsunami
took place on Saturday night but it's
only now that we're getting a really
comprehensive picture of the damage the
destruction along Indonesia's coastline
goes on for miles where the tsunami
smashed through homes communities and
resorts phone video captured the moment
it swept through a rock concert killing
all but one member of the band 17:00
their stage later washed up on the beach
police and rescue crews are still
combing remote areas helping to evacuate
stranded residents the disaster agency
estimates that more than 20,000 people
are now in shelters as for the volcano
an act Krakatoa it's been active on and
off for weeks it is still belching dust
and smoke so the sky around it is a
no-fly zone Indonesian authorities have
also banned anyone from going within
half a mile of the shore in case a fresh
eruption causes another tsunami heavy
clouds are making it hard to see the
volcano but new radar data confirms what
volcanologist suspected that Saturday's
eruption sent the entire south west side
of the mountain plunging into the sea
meanwhile the rescue effort is being
slowed down by bad weather believe it or
not torrential rain this in an area
already devastated by flooding from that
tsunami Dana they just can't get a break
there Elizabeth
Palmer in London thank you